in the near future entertainment studios
networks and companies with large
libraries of intellectual property will
find it's much cheaper to use artificial
intelligence to merge their various ips
together than it is to make new content
agree will in chat you must now imagine
an astonishing new property called
goodfellas hunting two an amalgam of
good fellas goodwill hunting and
terminator 2. that's right this is the
ip shuffle begin the okay okay the ip
shuffle now get it i fully agree with
doozy i think i don't know about these
three movies that it's making us do
goodfellas goodwill hunting and
terminator 2. those are all still owned
by are they owned by the same studio i
don't even know no i have no idea but i
like that the two is the reason for
terminator
being in there just using the two from
hey i think that's the best two
ever terminator two uh
revenge of the nerds nerds in paradise
is pretty good but uh yeah
yeah godfather two but i will say
what i think is the most likely one of
these to happen
a little nostrachatis right here out of
the segment is going to be a merger of
star wars and guardians of the galaxy or
the marvel universe because disney owns
both of those i think that we will see
that soon yeah well as far as dudesy is
concerned the hot properties are
good will hunting
good fellas
terminator 2. so what is that [ __ ]
movie like it's somebody has to get sent
back in time to stop a nuclear
apocalypse who is it matt damon joe
pesci
i think it's i think it's an amalgam it
has to be an amalgam of ray liotta matt
damon and eddie furlong okay
i don't know what that character is
but but okay so let's say let's say that
wait you're saying that those three
characters merge into one person or
they're like a team no i i'm saying that
it the the the character itself is sort
of an amalgam of those guys so perhaps a
you know a janitor who works at mit or
some sort of uh incredible uh ivy league
school or something okay is is uh also
who who's in the
he he's a his drug dealer by night yeah
that's associated with the mafia yes and
also he has a mom that everyone thinks
is a lunatic because she believes she
has future knowledge about a nuclear
apocalypse but she actually does and the
and how about the reason
that uh this rayleigh to matt damon
eddie furlong character
uh
you know what does this guy look like
this is just it's some kind of ai art
that just makes a new character that's
not a real person yes mixing those
people yeah okay
uh yeah and that character it wants to
like in in in good will hunting
uh robin williams basically cracks the
the fact that you know
will wants to
do something
with his life right he he he wants to do
something with his wife at the end of
the movie it's he goes off and you see
you know sorry i had to go see about a
girl see about a girl any and he follows
um minnie driver out to the west coast
uh where she's going to school and in
but but uh robin williams busts him with
that and says you could be a janitor
anywhere why would you want to be a
janitor at uh mit and then he and then
um
so what if what if
the matt damon ray leota eddie furlong
character is working something that he's
working on on that board has to do with
figuring out yes figuring out if his mom
is is nuts or
or he's secretly using mit's scientific
department to figure out if that is a
real thing and that's why then de niro
[ __ ] shows up in a bolt of lightning
and is like how about them apples
that's like
that's that is that's the robot from the
future yeah and i like that uh that
impersonation uh chad's robert de niro
is basically just rip torn
what it's just written torn from the no
this is my riptorn yeah what the hell
are we talking about you wanna hear my
impersonation of i forget this actor's
name but this is the the coach from
major league two not really major league
okay heart attack
thank you that's all i got that's pretty
good anyways
good what was a good good will every
time we win a game
one of these patches comes off yeah
that's the guy from from major league
too yeah oh he's also in a fantastic
yeah man one of one of the best movies
coupe de ville if you have the means i
don't even think it's streaming anywhere
i have a dvd copy and i have a vhs copy
that's cool yeah and then he's in that
that's really like that guy gave you
that hey boys come here we got a lot of
work to do speaking of a lot of work to
do good
fellas hunting too
yeah we got a lot of work to do with
that okay so it's about
a okay
it's about a janitor at mit
who also works for the mafia selling
drugs who has maybe a mom who's crazy
that thinks uh there's a future nuclear
calamity coming and he's using his
access to mit scientific uh
technologies to figure out if this is
true or not and then robert de niro
comes back from the future he's a robot
uh robert de niro is a robot and he
tries to kill this guy no how about he
how about instead of that he wants to be
his therapist
okay and he's like
it's not your fault well
right it's not your fault
it's not your fault
oh no not you please not you it's not
your fault well
it's not your fault but then he has a
group of friends that are also kind of
criminals like in the drug trade he has
these friends yeah and perhaps one of
them is like the joe pesci character but
it's arnold schwarzenegger okay
so he's like uh he's one of the drug
dealers yeah
he's not the terminator in this no i
think the terminator is robert de niro
but he's a therapist not a killing robot
the terminator is robert de niro
robert de niro as robin williams
but he's a therapist not a killing robot
and then i think you've got the joe
pesci character from goodfellas played
by arnold schwarzenegger but in this
context of a low-grade drug dealer who
is friends with the
matt damon
eddie furlong ray liotta character i
like it but it's not convoluted enough
please put on some layers
oh i don't i don't even know i i don't
even know so wait so robert de niro is
the terminator and they in arnold
schwarzenegger is the you know you know
the guy he said to me and he goes
what are you still doing here i thought
i told you to go [ __ ] your mother bing
bang
bang yeah with the you know when he's
like and then uh the matt damon ray
leota um eddie furlong character is like
how did eddie furlong what did he say in
that movie went cowabunga dude right
yeah no fate but what we made no faith
but what we make you're really funny
what do you mean funny how do you mean
i'm funny did you mean i'm a joke to you
they make laugh here don't worry you do
funny you said it you said it not me why
didn't you tell me yeah are you i'm a
clown do you
what are you saying why whether how do
you mean funny you you're funny how
[Laughter]
uh
so that's uh so then there's that and
then does he meet is there a love
interest like a mini driver
oh yeah who should that be or
bronco it's a mini driver lorraine
bronco right thing so she's she goes to
school let's just put her at the mit
thing even though the movie she goes to
have it
um and uh and she
let's revisit that what the hell
what the [ __ ] is this movie about what i
have no [ __ ] idea dude
these three movies they're so [ __ ]
desperate i have no idea how to put them
together you have to have these weird
sci-fi elements of time travel
potentially killer robots that are
coming back to wipe out the human race a
nuclear holocaust that happens at
terminator 2 yeah uh then you have you
know goodfellas is about like the mafia
drugs
murders and then
goodwill hunting is essentially about
like a genius wasting his talents yeah
uh and then and then what
i mean that's about it
i i don't know i mean it's it's hard to
put these three movies together but i
agree with doozy that this type of [ __ ]
is gonna happen i think you could also
see something like that guardians of the
galaxy star wars thing i can see a movie
getting made that is like chewbacca and
groot
in like a buddy space cop comedy where
they don't speak [ __ ] english the
whole time all right hold on
i am groot yeah we gotta do a whole
movie of that yeah we gotta do uh
goodfellas hunting too here though i
know what makes it a sequel
you
uh it's not your fault well okay yeah in
the first one
the good one the whatever the amalgam of
what is it ray leona eddie for longer
matt damon that guy invents time travel
at the end of the first movie and then
movie two is about de niro coming back
from the future to be his therapist
you're bound by nothing will
it's not your fault
um okay so he comes back
and that's the de niro character
oh holy [ __ ] and then and then and then
uh maybe we find out that the de niro
character actually has come back he says
that he's gonna be his therapist but
it's actually so that he can get access
to that drug circle and start selling
drugs and he's trying to take over eddie
furlong matt damon ray leota's territory
yeah and then uh and then
but then arnold uh pesci wants in
yeah and he's like yeah hold on a second
you know if you i know this isn't from
goodfellas it's from casino but he's
like
let me tell you something uh
you know robert de niro terminator
you shut my money off i'll shut your
[ __ ] brain off
you know
and i'll crack you in the head and just
when you're waking up in the hospital
i'll do it again you want to know why
because i'm stupid i don't give a [ __ ]
dude i would [ __ ] pay is there i mean
and i'm gonna pay but i was gonna say i
would pay to see arnold schwarzenegger
deep faked over like anybody in a
[ __ ] scorsese movie that would be so
[ __ ] good
geez dude this is
this is the most doozy episode of dudesy
ever yeah that's coming we're gonna be
able to put schwarzenegger and
goodfellas within five years i don't
want to i don't yes you do no i don't i
want you de niro is de niro
schwarzenegger schwarzenegger never the
two shawl meet yeah i'm a purist you
know that i'm not just appearance about
about professional wrestling i'm a
purist about
a few things dear bear being one of them
um
is there a bezel
thank you moving on i was gonna ask if
there's a
a ben affleck character in this thing
but
i don't know batman
yeah batman's in it too he just [ __ ]
shows up at a certain point maybe we'll
get back to goodfellas hunting too at
some point but i'm gonna i'm gonna have
to go google and see if this there's one
studio that owns all of those i don't
know if that's true or not i don't think
so but i think that'll be a key
component of how these these future
amalgams these future ip shuffles as
doozy said that's the only way they'll
work
yeah so so i guess chad's right art is
dead uh because now all we're doing is
just not dad dude just message new tools
to make brand new pieces of art new
forms of art that have never existed
before
technology always comes before art in
every [ __ ]
please tell a case then break the review
if you like dudes here's what you do
please tell a friend then